ich habe so hart dafür gearbeitet dass
es einen Kompromiss
gibt das ganze letzte Jahrzehnt über
aber mit der Hamas gibt es keine
Hoffnung
darauf was passiert denn dann nach der
nächsten Waffenruhe dann strebt i Hamas
wieder an die Macht und das kann einfach
nicht akzeptiert werden heramas muss
sich komplett
ergeben wir brauchen eine neue Art der
Vermittlung
mit der wir arbeiten können und ich kann
für mich sagen dass ich mich darauf
freue ich wünsche mir für uns alle eine
schönere Zukunft ich möchte dass wir
zusammen in diesem Land leben können
nicht einfach nur ein Land für ein
Volk und ich möchte dass wir alle hier
vereint
sind also rufen Sie nicht daav zu auf
dass Palästina befreit wird sondern dass
die Hamas sich ergibt